ez nagyon érdekes hogy egy olyan nyitott
közösséget írsz le amire nem gondoltam
volna hogy tényleg ilyen nyitott ez a
közösség egyrészt keresztényként te
tapasztaltál-e valamilyen elutasítást a
környezetedbe nem tapasztaltam semmit
mert én nem próbálom ráerőltetni a
intermet senkire igazából tehát én én
fordítva értem hogy hogy hogy hogy
izraelben a
zsidók esetleg elzárnak vagy vagy ki
elutasítanak amiatt mert nem zsidó vagy
ők elfogadnak engem zsidónak mivel
anyaiá vagyok anyaiáon vannak zsidó
felmé tehát elfogadnak ők téged zsidónak
annak ellenére hogy hogy te
kereszténynek tartad magad aki a
különbség van a a jog között ami ami jog
létezik az államban és a vallási jog
között és a a zsidó vallás szerint az a
zsidó aki anyajában
zsidó é és emiatt hogy is mondjam van
egy ilyen testvériség érzés